what um what's the best piece of a
financial investment advice you've ever
received right in terms of from another
investor what's the best piece of advice
I ever gave you well I have a friend
named Brent be sure and this is gonna be
advice through Brent because it didn't
come directly from Brent Brent is
fantastic it came from Warren Buffett
and Brent went to a dinner with him
and by the way full disclosure our
family is involved with an investment in
Brent anyway
Brent is a very detail-oriented guy and
a really super nice guy and you know he
wanted to hear all about Buffett's
diligence and you know he had his paper
ready to take his notes and Buffett
looked at him and he goes prices my only
diligence and as I kind of thought about
that I thought wow that is like really
brilliant right because at some point
everything gets worth buying if it's
functioning and you know it's not a
legal there's not some quagmire that
you're stepping into yep and and it's
kind of like yeah I mean ultimately
Jamie Diane Diamond once said give me a
C rank plan with a ranked players and
I'll take that all day long over an
a-rank plan with C rate players
mm-hmm so I think you know most
investment advice is really elemental
mm-hm and and it speaks to what I call
the wall well duh right you know so you
hear Buffett say prices my only
diligence and you think well if it
wasn't Warren Buffett no one would pay
the attention to him but they would they
would because when you think about it
and you wrap that around your head and
and I looked at Brimmer
Brenton went wow that's that's really
profound mm-hmm so I think one of the
things that I've been on
recently is look I believe that people
if they want to be great investors they
have to create their investment scheme
that's right for them mm-hmm what is
right for me might not be right for you
read as much as you can and read outside
the field of Finance definitely but as
you do that
take notes see what resonates with you
see what doesn't ask yourself would I
really be able to withstand that kind of
downturn and then ask yourself and not
even up more obvious question okay how
did I perform during the financial
crisis if I sold all my stocks in
January or February I know I got a
problem and then I got to try to build
an investment strategy that will work
for me listen good investing is simple
it's just not easy mm-hmm and and that
is you know something that a lot of
people you know go back to basic
principles and you know get somebody to
be a wingman for you because for the
most part you'll panic I used to say to
people you know do a letter from your
advisor that's from you that says dear
mr. advisor mrs. advisor I know that at
some point in the future I will panic
about you know and then leave a space
where you can fill it in and you are
gonna tell me what a stupid idea that is
for me and then show it to me at the
time again as long as human nature
remains what it is I got a day job